it's february 19 2022 and you're
watching the code report the results are
in approximately 15 000 web developers
filled out the state of javascript
survey and the results are shocking if
you choose to take them seriously
although it has a small sample size it
generates a lot of buzz on social media
and creates some badass data
visualizations which is all your boss
really cares about when choosing your
tech stack for the next decade the first
insight is that angular is on the rise
it went from being the second most hated
framework to still being the second most
hated framework but with a three percent
higher satisfaction rate the data is
misleading though and there's really
only one person to blame ben awad he
spreads dangerous misinformation about
angular just to impress women think of
react the library kind of like a
maserati whereas the framework angular
is kind of like a garbage truck based on
the news coverage and comments and its
tick tock it seems to be working but we
all know that angular is the goat
apparently the worst technology is gulp
which was the only one to land in box
four which means if you're using it you
are supposed to reassess your life
choices immediately that's pretty harsh
sir gulp deserves more respect than that
but the javascript build tool world is
absolutely ruthless another surprise was
to see vue.js fall in satisfaction there
are many potential reasons for this but
i think the biggest one is likely the
migration from view 2 to view 3. even
though the migration is seamless it made
the overall ecosystem more complex which
makes it a bit harder to learn than it
was previously in addition all
frameworks tend to decrease in
satisfaction over time there's the
initial honeymoon phase then to stay
relevant the framework needs to
implement all kinds of new features then
it becomes bloated and complex and
people stop liking it so they switch
over to new frameworks like solid svelte
and alpine and the cycle continues
forever and ever until the end of time
but the creator of you evan yu is also
the creator of the build tool vee with a
crazy high satisfaction rate of 98 i'm
not surprised at all because i was able
to quit drinking after i started using
it i try to never have to mess with
module bundlers but when i do i prefer
veed now when it comes to backend
frameworks gatsby went from 89
in 2019 to a shocking 51 in 2021. back
in 2019 graphql was the hottest thing
out there and people wanted to use it
everywhere even to build simple static
websites i think two years later people
have realized that that might not be the
best abstraction for the majority of
websites out there and now we have tools
like next.js and speltkit which also has
a ridiculous satisfaction rate making it
even harder for gatsby to stay
competitive now when it comes to
building mobile apps with javascript was
never meant to do that it seems like
most of the technologies trend pretty
aggressively downward ionic is trending
upward which means it's probably a
little underrated but one tool i'm
interested in checking out is tori which
is a rust-based alternative to electron
for building desktop apps in any case it
seems like almost everybody thinks that
javascript is moving in the right
direction overall although it is
trending downward from previous years
knowledge coalescing and optional
chaining are the most adopted recent
features and there are other features on
the way like the temporal api to make
javascript dates not suck so much
another big surprise for me was to find
fireship under people on the survey
buyership is not my real name for those
wondering but i do like to live a quiet
anonymous life in my mom's basement i
also got twice as many votes as ben awad
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and i will see you in the next
one